and she's whether some Lubbock Texas hi
Angie welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I'm mister Ramsey thank you so much for
taking my call
sure what's up um I got a quick question
my boyfriend is introduced me to your
baby steps and so I'm on baby step
number two I have 18,000 dollars saved
up and I have I was 13 on a car and then
I also have a t-1000 and student loan
debt which I just found out about so I
didn't know how how did you run up
student loan debt didn't know about it
well I thought that that's was paid for
and my parents said that they were going
to pay for my Master's and then I went
ahead and got my doctorate because I
work in Texas and so we got $17,000 back
for that and so unfortunately I guess my
mom was buying member money off my name
and I didn't know that and so now I have
a t-1000 that I need to pay off and I
had to flip that much you sign the
paperwork
well she had my name and everything in
the computer and for that time she did
it well that's called identity theft
that's criminal god yes yeah but I
shouldn't have been blind and so this is
a t-1000 I need to figure out stop stop
just singing okay okay your mother stole
your identity and borrowed money without
your permission well I gave her my
information because I thought she was
like checking my grades and stuff yes I
was just kind of blind to the situation
you're misunderstanding me Angie I'm not
asking a question I'm making a statement
you know a mother stole your identity
and borrowed money without your
permission yes that is a criminal act
yes you're not liable when someone
steals your identity for the dad your
mother is liable for that debt
you really this is so what is I mean
you're much so this must have destroyed
your relationship with your mother yes
because there's him I try to talk to her
about it she just cries so but yes so
what is your parents financial situation
not good not good and he still take care
of mine mister IVA twin sister and they
take care of her still and pay all her
bills because she can't afford it hdn
it's an educational leadership as my
plan is to be for society University and
so right now I'm just a high school
teacher and coach making 63 so I think I
can really get this eighty one thousand
and paid off quickly if I just work hard
on it okay and you said you have
eighteen in savings yes thirteen I
borrow your car off today pay it off
today okay and don't have anything
coming out of your check no retirement
coming out of your check and then let's
lean into this eighty one and pay it off
as soon as you can I'm so sorry you've
been a victim of this from your own
mother but if we leave her if we leave
this on her she'll end up going to jail
so it sounds like you're paying it Wow
unbelievable
so yeah and you know get the
professorship as fast as possible
because that'll at least double your
income and that'll help you plow through
this as well I'm sorry